hello everyone and welcome to the start
of the norway just before the actual
classical event we're gonna have a blitz
tournament it's magnus cross and versus
maxim bashir lagrave with a very nice
game in round two where uh things go
crazy at already at the start of the
game basically on move four or okay
maybe move five uh you'll see what i
mean by this so let's dive straight into
it and uh enjoy it remember it's a blitz
game uh so not a lot of time to
think about the moves and that's exactly
why the lines get
this
this insane uh so magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening we have e5 g3 c6
and now pawn to d for striking in the
center maximum advance this is pawn to
e4 and magnus advances his pawn to d5
and
usually bishop to b4 check is the
is the move you play here however maxine
plays knight to f6
and he now invites magnus to
push this pawn all the way to d6 and
pretty much uh prevent maxime from
developing his dark square bishop and
this is exactly what uh
magnus does he pushes d6 and it is now
already as of move five that we have a
completely new game uh no wonder as who
who would allow such a thing well maxine
would as he wants to get some very
active play even at the cost of some
material so here g6 right away he wants
the fiance to bishop castle his king to
safety and uh well force the magnus to
wait waste some time grabbing the pawn
uh pawn on e4 and hopefully get some
sort of an attack going so knight to c3
bishop to g7 and the bishop the g2 and
now
okay the e4 pawn is hanging maybe maxim
could defend it with queen to a5 pinning
the knight but he doesn't care about the
pawn he just castles he says you go
after the pawn your king is still on e1
you still have to move the knight and
the den castle so hopefully i'm going to
get some sort of an attack here so
magnus captures the pawn we have knight
captures on f3 bishop captures and rook
to e8 and already the rook is uh
in the attack the it comes into the game
with tempo so bishop has to move the
show back to g2 and queen to a5 with
check we have bishop to d2 and queen c5
now uh we're threatening to capture this
pawn this pawn this pawn and the magnus
needs to do something about this so he
plays bishop to c3 now the b2 and the d6
pawn are defended and maxime captures on
c3 doubling carlson c3 uh c pawn uh
captures captures and queen captures and
c4 now threatening queen captures on c3
so magnus defends it and now comes pawn
to b6 uh magnus now strikes with h4 he
wants to play h5 and open up the h file
and now pawn to h5 maxime of course
prevents this and here comes a really
really awesome moment in the game uh
magnus plays knight the h3 he wants the
uh well he has some attacking ideas of
maybe just moving the king maybe bring
the queen to h6 put the knight in g5
quickly uh chuck made the black king but
he completely blunders the game away so
feel free to pause the video here and
find the winning idea for maxime while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
this is just happening and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is rook captures an e2 with czech of
course and now you don't have a good
move you can't capture with the king you
have to capture with the queen now queen
captures on c3 with check now the rook
falls and you can defend a little bit
let's say queen e5 check we need to we
happily trade queens and that's it
bishop basics check we're up two pawns
with black this is easily winning for
maxine
but maxime as usual doesn't expect
magnus to make such a big blunder and he
just continues developing knight to a6
magnus quickly castles the safety and
now knight to c5 we have rook f31 and
bishop to a6 now putting a lot of
pressure here on this e2 pawn so bishop
f3 defending it and now knight to e4
attacking the queen and now the question
is do you bring the queen to h6 and even
though of course it looks like a great
move after this move uh we can't really
do anything about knight to g5 of course
we want to capture and play knight g5 uh
but maxine would just go back and okay
you can get your knight to g5 but
nothing is happening really the uh the
black knight on f6 controls the h7
square uh so
this is nothing basically you've just
trapped your queen on h6 for for no good
reason so here magnus plays bishop
captures on e4 instead now the knight
will be uh
unable to help out with the defense of
the mating attack rook captures an e4
and queen to h6 now the 80s of course
knight g5 queen h7 queen f7 okay we
can't play queen f7 the queen covers
this but it's gonna be a very very
strong attack so rookie five we simply
cannot allow that knight to have the g5
square even at the price of some
material sony g5 and rook captures on g5
maxim has to give up the exchange now h
captures and g5 would be pointless you
would just trap your queen on h6 so
queen captures and g5 was played rook to
e8 and now we have queen back to d2 just
adding a defender to the e2 pawn and you
don't really
i mean you could trade for example rook
captures on e2 but that's really nothing
real captures queen captures queen
captures bishop captures and the
resulting end game is of course winning
for white it's a bishop against uh a
rook so instead we have c5 uh we have f3
by magnus preparing e4 and the bishop to
be seven we have king to f2 rook to e6
and now ponte a4 we have pawn to a sorry
not pawn to a5 bishop to c6 now
and magnus advances the pawn to a5 we
have b5 and now a6 grabbing more space
on the queen side
rook to e5 and now uh pawn to e4 and now
how can
magnus make some progress here it's not
going to be easy maxine uh
uh
well uh
created a blockade in the center and now
he wants to play b4 and create a past b
pawn so here we have queen to e6
bringing the queen back rook 8 to d1 and
now king to g7 we have queen to f4 by
magnus and f6 now
we have g4 and now g5 chasing away the
queen uh queen back to g3 uh or you
could capture here it seems like uh like
like a nice idea but
uh it's a blizz game you don't have all
that much time on the clock but it does
make sense to open up the king like this
play king to h2 queen h2 attacked the
pawn and once the position gets
blockaded there's this wonderful rook to
d5 idea
but this is very very difficult to find
point is that if captures captures uh
that's uh
very tricky rook captures an e1 and now
comes d captures on e6 so uh you you
can't really do that and uh well what
can you do you have to move the queen or
something
but it's not great if uh
you move the queen then we just play
queen captures and e5 with check we end
up up a whole rook so everything is
completely winning here but it's a blitz
game so queen back to g3 h captures on
g4 we have h capture sun g g5 rook
captures on g5 and now f4 grabbing more
space here attacking the rook rook to h5
and now f5 attacking the queen and now
queen b3 is actually very very
resourceful for black
but it's uh you know uh getting the
queen uh so far away from the defense of
your own king it just looks silly but if
queen captures on g for check rook g5
and you're you're okay once the queen
moves you you deliver a check here and
you know a lot of squares are controlled
by by black here if rook to d2 queen
captures on c3 it's still a game however
queen to f7 was played here it seems
like it's even better as it adds more
protection to the rook and the maxim
wants to hide his king over to the queen
side but this doesn't work queen
captures on g4 with check king to f8 and
now feel free to pause the video and try
and see if you have the positional sense
of a magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh finding this
move it's not an easy move to find but
if you've studied the position then uh
you you've
no doubt found it and that is rook to h1
rook to g1 is strong rook to h1 is just
crushing there is no defense against
rook to h1 magnus plays this and now
it's very very difficult the problem is
your rook here is attacked if you if you
trade rook captures rook captures how do
you defend against rook h8 uh the the
pawn car covers the e7 square so the
king doesn't really have any squares and
if queen g7 offering a queen trade we
just play queen h4 now rook g1 is coming
and there's no defense against that so
instead maxime tried the queen to 82
with check but now magnus just goes back
queen to e2 and now you have to trade
queens because the rook is hanging so
queen captures with chuck king captures
rook captures rook captures and bishop
captures an e4 attacking the rook and
maksim is up upon but still it's a rook
against the bishop and magnus
immediately goes after this a7 pawn
that's on a dark square so it's going to
be
uh
very easy to capture it king of seven
now first king e3 attacking the bishop
if the bishop captures here doesn't
really matter so maxine brings the the
bishop back uh we have rooked the c8 and
now going after the
uh c7 square if you captured here then
rook a8 immediately works because the
bishop no longer has control over the a8
square so b4 maxim now creates a pass b
pawn c character c captures and now rook
to c7 there's no defending this b3 king
to d2 we have to stop the past b pawn
bishop to e4 now and here would be a
perfect moment to mess up the entire
game for magnus if he were to capture on
a7 because then b2 wins uh the pawn
covers c1 bishop covers c2 so the king
cannot
get near the pawn and of course you
don't have rook b7 as the bishop covers
that as well so that would be pretty
terrible but magnus plays rook captures
on d7 with check and now it doesn't
matter what black plays because next
move we just bring the king closer
and the pawn will never reach the b to
dark square but here king the e8 was
played so magnus just played rook t it's
a e7 check and he was in this position
on move 50 that maksim vashilagrav
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the king moves
we're just going to capture the bishop
and now the bishop no longer helps out
with the control of anything and also
you can just bring the rook to b4 so
it's very easy to stop the past pawn
so yeah
very nicely done congratulations to
magnus on this very nice game but also
to maxime uh on making things extremely
interesting and always uh you know
bringing the best for for the chess
world uh it's never boring when when
maxine plays especially i mean he brings
uh some crazy lines even in classical
and rapid but in blitz uh
he always delivers uh so um this was a
very fine idea knight to f6 by maxime uh
trying to get magnus to overextend and
then uh sort of make a counter attack
with carlson's king still being stuck in
the center
but it just didn't work out it almost
did after magnus played this knight to
h3 if only the maximum spotted rook
captures an eq
but
unfortunately for maxim that didn't
happen so yeah that's the game i hope
you enjoyed it uh always expect the
unexpected even if your opponent is an
extremely strong player he can always
make a move that blunders the game
completely so you know always trust
yourself and check everything your
opponent does i would like to thank
first elden lord nagarjuna ponogoti
congrats harry three grants andre theron
and alexander john huart for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
norway chess most likely until it ends
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day